easiest way to get the number of  somebody who's ahead of you in business  and life is instead of asking them  directly for their number what you do is  you ask them if they would be opposed to  giving you their number so it sounds  like this hey would it be totally  overstepping for me to exchange digits  with you right now so we can do xyz  later and when you ask like that we're  actually asking a different question but  in so doing we actually accomplished the  result of them saying no it wouldn't be  totally overstepping free to ask and  then the implication is yes i will give  you my number and so that's the beauty  of the question and it works every time